de gigantesques nuages noirs
s'accumulent dans le ciel de calcutta
voici les prémices du cyclone en panne
qui pourrait être le plus violent a
frappé le sous continent indien depuis
attendu ce mercredi après midi il
pourrait s'accompagner de vents
soufflant jusqu'à 180 km/heure la menace
est prise très au sérieux par les
autorités
munis de haut parleurs des policiers
ordonnent aux habitants de se mettre à
l'abri rapidement une recommandation
bien difficile à mettre en oeuvre pour
ceux qui vivent dans des habitations
rudimentaire je pars avec les membres de
ma famille ab legata chez ma fille pour
éviter le cyclone une fois la tempête
passée je reviendrai au bangladesh
voisin les évacuations déjà commencé
dans les régions côtières
particulièrement menacée par une montée
des eaux
des milliers de personnes habitant sur
des îles isolées sont déplacées par des
gardes-côtes en tenue de protection car
c'est une autre menace qui complexifie
leur tâche l'épidémie de coronavirus
pour éviter une contamination massive
pendant le passage du cyclone
les autorités rappellent la nécessité de
porter un masque et de respecter les
distances de sécurité
des mesures de précaution ont aussi été
prises dans les refuges
nous avons déjà préparé environ une
quinzaine d'abris anti cyclonique sur
les côtes du bangladesh
ils ont été complètement désinfecter
nous apportons ensuite du matériel
supplémentaire comme des bâches en
plastique pour que les gens puissent
avoir des pièces est parue nous nous
assurons aussi qu'ils aient des
fournitures telles que du savon on gèle
pour les membres des produits de
nettoyage pour les toilettes et tout ce
qui est nécessaire aux populations
au bangladesh les autorités expliquent
vouloir déplacer plus de deux millions
de personnes tandis qu'en inde le
gouvernement assure disposer de
suffisamment d'abri pour héberger plus
d'un million d'habitants dans l'état
d'audi chat en 2007 le cyclone sidr
avait fait près de 3500 morts lors de
son passage sur le sous continent indien
[Musique]